una crisis inesperada agita la asamblea
general de la onu el conflicto por el
pacto de defensa al curso tomó el
protagonismo en nueva york y la unión
europea se abroqueló en apoyo a francia
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der layen acusó un
tratamiento inaceptable contra su país
miembro y el líder del consejo europeo
charles michel denunció la falta de
lealtad de eeuu palabras a las que
adhirió el ministro de exteriores
francés él se da por la crisis de la
juventud confiamos otro torneo
lo que importa ahora es la ruptura de la
confianza entre socios porque la
confianza y la camaradería entre aliados
requiere transparencia previsibilidad y
explicaciones hablar entre ellos no
esconderse unos de otros particularmente
en asuntos de importancia y todo eso no
ha ocurrido
con paz y crisol y sustancial obtención
de activo modelo el bloque europeo
trasladó sus preocupaciones a australia
alegando falta de consultas y la
exclusión de los socios europeos en el
acuerdo tripartito el primer ministro
británico intentó calmar los ánimos
reino unido y francia tienen una
relación muy muy importante e
indestructible y por supuesto hablaremos
con todos nuestros amigos sobre cómo
hacer que el pacto baucus funcione para
que no sea excluyente ni divisivo no
tiene por qué ser de esa manera a mí
welliton hard vida web el sorpresivo
acuerdo prevé que australia adquiera al
menos ocho submarinos nucleares a eeuu y
reino unido un pacto visto como un
intento de frenar la influencia de china
en la región indo pacífico
el daño colateral fue la cancelación
repentina de un contrato entre australia
y francia para la compra de submarinos
por unos 30.000 millones de euros un
movimiento calificado por parís de
puñalada por la espalda